the Joe Rogan experience yeah well
that's oftentimes the case the
difference between someone who just does
fantastic and someone who just doesn't
quite just someone who falls off short
yeah I think it also comes from like you
know the the way you come up in the
sport some of these guys they come up
and they're the best guy in there in
their area for a long time and you kind
of get this attitude or this you start
developing this persona of like I don't
have to do all that work cuz like I'm
not even doing that much and I'm still
smashing everybody in here well that's
where it's crazy about a guy like John
Jones he actually can do that yeah he's
one of the rare guys that actually can
do that man I like I wonder how much
money he's left on the table with with
all these problems especially with the
attention that Connors brought to the
sport yeah and a guy like John Jones
yeah you know I know good as he is good
as he is and it's I feel like for the
longest time to he's trying to push this
goody-two-shoes image and everybody was
like well that's not you oh yeah this is
fake and then all of his problems sort
of forced him to just be himself and
then people like we like you more now
yeah and any ones have tested positive
for something else which I believe him
it was accidental I believe that it was
accidental in this in this case because
it doesn't make any sense any other way
because if you look at how he tested
positive and what he tested positive for
and how recently tested negative before
that and how recently afterwards you
tested negative you're talking about
something that was a such a miniscule
trace amount there's no way you can
consider taking something like that and
having it have some sort of positive
effect you know performance enhancing
effect now was that the the substance is
it oral is it can it be taken already be
taken or okay yeah so I've heard
I've heard and I don't know how true
this is I would expect it to be somewhat
true but I've heard like in boxing you
know you main eventers they've had these
these issues where they would only they
would provide their own food because
they don't trust the stuff somebody you
know
spiking their food with something so
they test
so I don't um I mean that sounds
far-fetched but it also sounds to some
degree reasonable his position was
weakened by his testimony in the
California State Athletic Commission
hearing because he first of all I said
that Malky had forged his signature on
one of the documents and one of the
things that he was supposed to have gone
over like what you can and can't I don't
know I think was he you sada paperwork
or maybe was California State Athletic
mentioned commissioned paperwork he
apparently admitted that his manager
forged his signature and they asked him
have you ever considered getting a new
manager yeah and he joked around but
yeah he has said no I'm just kidding but
that's not good and then there was a
bunch of stuff in like what he provided
as a possible source of that stuff you
know like he didn't he didn't have in
these a lot of the things that he
provided as a source of stuff in his
list of stuff that he had taken yeah you
know there's a lot going on there man
but the real problem is like John at one
point in Thomas being represented by
Nike I mean he was representing Nike he
was he had a huge Nike contract yeah
that's and that's huge I mean damn that
was giant Reebok - yeah that was the pre
pre Reebok days where he would've got
all the juice he would have got at all
and you know what can that coulda
shoulda woulda [ __ ] goes on forever and
on top on top of that um it coulda
woulda shoulda of that being pre Reebok
and it being Nike with everything that's
come to the sports since then imagine if
John like he could like he could have
done it gone - Jordan route in some
sense you know yeah way he's got a whole
line of John Jones Sheree type [ __ ]
that's nice sure right you know he could
be the heavyweight champion right now
who knows I mean who knows well he could
absolutely absolutely he could be in a
super fight with steep a yeah absolutely
100% absolutely that would be a huge
[ __ ] fight man for MMA John coming up
to heavyweight I mean it's a huge fight
with DC coming up to heavyweight yes you
know and the only got the only guy to
have a best time is John and not just
best to me K Odom
you know I mean he hit him with that
left high kick that that DC said you're
not gonna hit me with that left kick
yeah literally said that because he was
saying he exposes some tendencies like
oh you mean the left kick you're not
gonna hit me with that left high kick
and then boom he lands the left high
kick now is that like the Titanic a
little bit like it only sank because
they said it wouldn't yeah maybe that's
kind of crazy yeah
[Applause]